turning now to an essay contest among
young people that gives us remarkable
insight into a lost history you could
say the recently unearthed essays were
written by jewish people living in
eastern europe in the 1930s right before
world war ii and the holocaust now the
word is getting to hear some of their
facets now the world rather is getting
to hear some of their fascinating
stories
jim axelrod shows us how they're part of
a new graphic novel
the basement where cartoonist ken
krimstein offers his takes on
contemporary life is just outside
chicago your chosen method here of
communication is not just words
but pictures
but lately his attention's been focused
5000 miles away on vilnius lithuania
and an essay contest for jewish
teenagers held more than 80 years ago
what grabbed you there were little
details in there this one listened to
records this one
went ice skating and i was like these
are real people
the contest was sponsored by eva an
organization founded in 1925 in vilnius
to preserve jewish culture it was a very
fantastic time
of dreaming and dreading jonathan brent
is the executive director and ceo of evo
now headquartered in new york the future
was on the one hand very optimistically
thought of by many people and on the
other hand the storm clouds were
gathering because of the rise of nazism
the contest asked teens to describe
their lives evo curator eddie portnoy
this is from an anonymous person who
signed this for guest
forget me not
entries were anonymous
to elicit unvarnished takes from the
next generation
on what their futures might look like
here is a real father who abandons a
mother here is a loving couple here is a
divorce here are all of the problems
here is a broad
swath
of
humanity of humanity exactly
a winner set to be announced september
1st 1939
was never named after hitler invaded
poland that very same day
the nazis plundered jewish artifacts
including some of the essays and shipped
them back to germany where they were
later found by the us army other entries
were hidden
in 2017 a bunch were discovered in a
church in vilnius i was like my god
these stories need to be told krimstein
pulled six for his new graphic novel
when i grow up
the eighth daughter a 19 year old
feminist forbidden to pray for her
father when he died the guy said to her
you know a woman's prayer isn't worth
anything her comeback for the first time
i began not to understand god the letter
writer a 20 year old young man reaching
out to america for a visa he never got
what do you think happened
he probably perished i i i shudder to
think of what happened to him actually
the folk singer who loved music but
couldn't pursue it
the boy who liked a girl
the ice skater and a rule breaker who
entered the contest even though she was
just 11 and a half i did feel an
obligation i didn't have their names but
maybe they could live again
when the new york times ran a story on
the found essays in 2017
it included a rare picture found on the
cover of one and so my sister forwarded
it to me and we both looked at him like
oh my god that's mom
the rule breaker had a name
beba epstein who survived three
different concentration camps this was a
baba
you hadn't known really didn't know her
five years after his mother's death
michael leventhal discovered much more
about her life to hear it in the voice
of an 11 year old that's just something
you don't get to do
has baba's
family seen your drawings they have and
they liked them
thank goodness
in telling beba's story and five others
whose names we don't know
ken krimstein hopes to illuminate what
we share
and warn us all against making anyone
else
the other you have kids talking about
hopes dreams challenges the one thing
you never hear these kids consider is
annihilation yeah and who could have
i mean how can you even we
we can't even understand it today
it's powerful stuff jim you know it is a
shared humanity hope streams boy likes
girl you know i got to tell you there
was such a um
pervasive feeling of sadness as i was
reporting the story that didn't leave me
there is something about ken crimstein
finding these
and and writing this book this graphic
novel
that there's just something about the
fact that the stories are not lost
forever that allows these kids nameless
mostly but still allows them to live on
it's the stories of those kids but it's
just stories of human beings out there
in the world that's a reminder it's our
humanity our shared humanity jim thank
you very much